the ACLU from the beginning has always
defended the rights of all persons
against abuses by the United States
government I said this way at the
beginning and so it's not limited
geographically it is limited by who the
government officials are so even if an
American citizen in this country were
abused by a Mexican government official
I mean we would maybe go after the US
government for not sufficiently
protecting against Mexican official but
it doesn't matter what the person's
citizenship is or where they are located
our government is always accountable to
constitutional standards and other legal
standards including honor under
international law regardless of where or
home it is using its power are aware or
against whom and and so you know one of
the first issues that the ACLU dealt
with right at the very beginning of its
existence was rights of immigrants I
mean there were the Palmer Raids and
people who were treated as having no
rights among other reasons because they
were non-citizens and you know here we
have a very strong constitutional leg to
stand on if you look at provisions in
the Constitution some of them do apply
to citizens but the most fundamental
rights are explicitly granted to persons
and so when you know that you know the
framers in two different clauses of the
very same amendment one of them talks
about citizens and the other one talks
about persons they were deliberately
saying it doesn't matter what your
citizenship status is you still are
entitled to fundamental due process
rights to fundamental equal protection
rights they may not be exactly the same
process that's due to a citizen but
there certainly are there and and I
don't know a single Supreme Court
justice who has disagreed with that
position you know you can fight about
the details of exactly what the rights
are that are due but so that's something
that we've always taken a position on
where there's more debate now and it's
an issue
is before the Supreme Court in the last
case arising out of Guantanamo that it
heard arguments on in December and that
is when the United States government
acts against anybody outside of our
territorial jurisdiction and it becomes
more pointed if you're talking about a
non citizen and the ACLU actually filed
a brief in that case in which we argued
specifically that the Constitution is
not limited geographically and in
particular they're a great right of
habeas corpus that allows somebody to go
before a judge to challenge the fact
that he or she is being detained by the
government is something that should
pertain regardless of geography and
regardless of citizenship the lower
court had reached and the opposite
holding and the brief is very persuasive
if you look at all the precedents you
know where something occurs and who the
victim is is a factor but it's not
conclusive
you